uh what are the upcoming
uh Milestones expected milestones and I
think um there's one in particular I'd
like to talk to you more about but
leading up to that of course is like
what what are some of the tests here on
the way so this is the static fire uh
the the fully stacked with the two
stages
uh will there be uh and then all that
leading to an orbital
launch test uh what so what other things
you should know about and what do you
think like what what do you think the
timeline will be with like the orbital
test timeline uh the reason we have this
website the expected Milestones is
because I always tell people to ignore
any time you ever hear for any of this
stuff yeah just pay attention to
Milestones because when you're doing
stuff for the first time you know you
just have no idea so just to understand
the expected Milestones here the First
Column is the event the the second
columns the date and Status TBD complete
green means what green means it's been
completed and it shows the completion
date there and the completion date yeah
and then the others maybe maybe more
maybe not for the full full stack
testing the d-stack and the there's a 33
engine so so realistically we're
expecting them to de-stack and SpaceX I
think distributed that actually they're
going to be de-stacking
um the second stage from the first stage
kind of get the ship safe while they
test because they don't want to you know
33 engines is pretty high risk if they
do blow up the rocket if when they test
it for the first time it's not going to
be fully fueled I don't think at least
but there is a limit to how they do have
to have it weighed down enough that the
launch clamps can hold on to it because
if you think about it like normally the
launch clamps are holding on to an
entire rocket weighing 5 million
kilograms five million I get you know
it's weighing an insane amount so those
clamps don't actually have to hold 75
Mega Newtons of thrust they really want
to have to hold down 25 Mega Newtons of
thrust you know what I mean they're not
designed to hold down all 75. so they do
have to have enough weight on the rocket
so that so even when they do these the
testing of the 33 engines it'll have to
have enough propellant in there that
they don't exceed the clamping and the
holding force of the stand otherwise
it'll break free from the launch stand
and that booster will go flying off
uncontrolled so it's a difficult thing
to figure out in the test how many uh
simultaneous things you test right so
they're kind of mitigating risks which
is why like they're d-stack you know
they don't want to have although the
ship could be on top of it to help weigh
it down and simulate the you know the
launch environment better at some point
that's a risk they're just going to take
when they go for launch and so for now
they're taking the ship off in case
something goes wrong during the 33
engine test and then once we see if the
33 engine test goes well hopefully we
see the the second stage get stacked
back on it we'll see him get closer like
closing out all the items and hope the
big one too is the FAA launch license
there that's a that'll be publicly filed
we'll see that you know in the system uh
having a launch license and I I have no
sense in that type of thing you know
that's outside of but that's but that is
a big milestone and it might be
something that could potentially hinder
uh you know hold up the launch date
would just be waiting for a launch
license
yeah I'm sure there's a lot of
fascinating bureaucracy and politics and
uh
legal stuff and all that kind of
beautiful magical thing when you live in
reality because it is I mean it is a big
uh rocket yeah one the biggest thing
it's not so much the fa doesn't
necessarily care about the success of
the rocket they just really just care
about the safety of public and public
property you know so it's it's it's a
matter of being convinced and having the
the data to prove okay if this thing
blows up we have a control of how and
when it blows up we have control of you
know X Y and Z here's the potential
damage here's the blast radius you know
this again is over twice as powerful and
twice as much potential actually it's a
lot more potential for uh an explosive
energy if it you know where it happened
to well let me walk back a little
because in order to have a real
detonation you have to have a perfect
mixture ratio of of your fuel and
oxidizer
um if when a rocket blows up typically
you know it kind of unzips and some of
the fuel will mix into some of the
oxidizer and you could have some
explosive energy but a lot of it's
actually just a deflagration it's just
you know flames and and yeah there will
there would be explosive energy but it's
not like you're lighting all of it
simultaneously it's this giant bomb it's
just really not so that's good but at
the same time even in those
circumstances the amount of energy is
still absurd enough to likely blow out
windows you know for miles and miles and
miles including my studio space
uh well if the cameras hold up it would
be one heck of a show hopefully of
course would not uh would not happen so
how does that take us to an orbital
launch when do you think that would
happen
in in my opinion uh this is a very fluid
and this will change literally by the
hour so you really think that it's very
difficult to really say like even even
for something that could very well
happen this year even just a few months
away
um making a prediction uh by the way you
like superstitious on this kind of stuff
a little bit like you don't you're
worried about jinxing it and that kind
of stuff no
um because I would imagine you would be
like waiting for all of these launches
that keep getting delayed or you start
thinking that there's certain things you
do will control the weather my socks why
am I wearing these socks I just scrubbed
again you know like yeah you're lucky
you have to wear the same lucky socks
otherwise it's going to there's going to
be bad weather yeah so the reason that I
say this and why it's so difficult is
they did a first full stack test in July
of 2021 and the expectation was we're a
month or two away from a launch yeah so
like realistically for 18 months I've
been in a Purgatory thinking that we're
a month or two away of an orbital launch
now I did say for the record heard when
that thing stacked and when a lot of
speculation was saying you know a month
or two I was saying I don't expect it to
fly in 2021. you know and I've been just
say I just saw the amount of work that
still needed to be done like the ground
systems the tanks the the launch Mount
all the stuff I'm sitting there like
there's still a lot of stuff they're
gonna have to validate it they're gonna
have to test everything every component
and you know people were like how dare
you say that even Gwen Shotwell the
president of SpaceX is saying Q3 of 2021
I'm like okay but like I'm just I'm not
gonna be surprised if it slips into
2022. and here we are the beginning of
2023 and I I think we're finally within
like two months
I I'm expecting like I'm trying to keep
my March in April as free as I can
we'll put it that way